(audience applauding)
- Good to see everybody.
- [Kelly] I forget how tall you are.
- [Tyler] Yeah. I'm so glad to see people.
- [Kelly] I know.
- I'm so glad to see people.
- I know. Give it up! Okay!
- [Tyler] We're not live, right?
- No, we're not live. Yeah.
- Okay.
♪ What if I told you ♪
(Kelly laughing)
♪ It was all meant to be ♪
- Come on. Sing it, sing it with me.
- [Kelly] Do I know the words?
♪ Would you believe me ♪
Is that it?
- Yeah. I was in the wrong key.
Yes, that's it. Would you agree?
- [Kelly] Would you agree?
- No. You would believe, would you agree.
- Okay, Here's the thing.
How are you with memorizing things?
- Okay. So we're even okay.
- I was like, I am not
good at memorizing things.
- But that means so much to me, because...
- [Kelly] Really?
- Oh yeah, when I first
did my play here in LA,
it was the first time. I was driving home.
That song came on the radio.
I was in tears because it
was like, it was a moment.
A great moment for me. So yeah.
You mean that much to me.
I just, I love it.
I'm sorry go on...
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- I love that that song did that for you.
I have songs like that in my
own life that I'm like, oh
that's the song that
inspired me. I love that.
I have to say this,
I did not know that you
had a house in Wyoming.
I didn't know that you
lived in Wyoming as well.
I live in Montana as well.
- Yeah.
- I have a ranch in Montana,
so I didn't know that you
had a place in Wyoming.
You like it up there? You
like the snow? All that?
- Yeah. I knew about your ranch
but you didn't know about mine?
- I didn't. I am the worst.
I literally just went to dinner last night
and found out all this
information from friends.
I don't know things, 'cause
I'm not on social media.
I'm on, like I put stuff out and say, "Hey
post this or something,"
but I'm not on it.
'Cause I saw "Social
Dilemma" and I freaked out.
- Yeah, we are the same people.
I'm the same way.
- I don't want to be that tapped in.
- Nope. Don't wanna be that tapped in.
I don't wanna be tracked
every five minutes.
I don't want people to
know everything I'm doing.
"Oh, I'm having breakfast.
Look at my sandwich."
What are we doing here?
- Yeah, yeah.
- But no, Jackson for me is,
I mean it's God's country, big open sky,
fresh air, I love the snow.
I love being visited by
the animals and the views.
- [Kelly] Cute town.
- The Tetons. Yeah, cute towns.
- I noticed in your pictures,
I was like oh my God
I've been there. It's beautiful.
I went to Montana rather than Wyoming.
It's a little less as cold
as it gets where you are.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- It's real cold. Where you go.
- It's real cold. I'm actually looking
to go to Colorado next because
as much as I love Jackson,
I wanted more space and
just, I like being alone.
I'm a loner by nature. I love being alone.
- Me too! Everybody thinks
that you have to like,
and I'm like, I enjoy my...
'Cause I feel like we're surrounded.
- [Tyler] All day.
- Not just in the industry.
If you're a teacher, if
you're whatever you do,
we're always surrounded by people.
- Yeah.
- It's nice to be alone.
- Yeah. And so I only have one kid though.
- Okay, I have two.
- Yeah. Which is a lot
for me. Two is a lot.
- Well, when you have two,
they start to play together.
- That's exactly...
- They You have time to pee alone.
- Yeah. That's exactly right.
(audience applauding)
You're right. Yeah, but
I'm one and done for me.
But, I love being in Jackson.
I love the fresh air.
I love it all.
- [Kelly] Oh man. It's
so nice. I hear that.
I have moose on my property.
You have moose as well?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- But your moose...
- But we're on their property.
- [Kelly] That's true.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Well it's all borrowed property.
We're all terminal at some point.
- [Tyler] 100%.
- But no, my moose, they
stay in the wooded areas.
- I love that you call your
moose, did you name them?
- My moose, I own them.
- You didn't yeah.
- No, I just mean, I see
them in like the woods.
They don't ever come up to my house,
but yours literally sit
in front of your door.
- Oh yeah. In front of the door.
The first time I ever saw one...
- [Kelly] They're dangerous.
- Yeah. They're very dangerous.
I was working out in the gym.
The garage doors were open.
I'm working out and this
huge shadow pass by,
and I go, what is that? It's this moose.
He's about nine feet tall with
the antlers and everything.
- Rack is huge.Yeah.
- I was like, oh my gosh! But yeah.
- And they're terrifying.
- And there's a place
where I sit and write
around a little fire pit and they love it.
He'll go out there and he
tearing up the chairs and all.
So I'm like, listen, you were here first.
You could have it. I'll just
stay up here in the house.
(Kelly laughing)
I'm not going out there.
- Not going near that chair.
So last time you were
here I thought you said
you were like, "No, I'm done with Madea."
And I love that you brought her back.
I feel like we need
her. She makes me laugh.
(audience cheering)
- I tell you...
- She makes me so happy.
- I tell you what happened,
and that's exactly why I brought it back.
Looking at the pandemic,
looking at all the social
and civil unrest, looking at
all the madness and looking
at everything that's
happening in the country.
I'm like, we need to laugh.
All of our smiles were covered up.
I'm like, what do I have in my toolbox
that will make people laugh?
And I open it up and
somebody says, "Hello!"
And here we are so yeah,
on Netflix. I'm excited.
- I know it makes me so happy.
And I love this was specific.
You spoke about LGBTQ
community in this one,
and I think it's cool.
It's a different message for this "Madea."
Was that really important to you?
- Yeah, again, looking at
the trauma and the heartache
and how much every everybody
has to say about other people
and the way they live their lives.
You get one life, life is short, right.
So I wanted to show a gay character,
coming out to his family, a Black family.
And they're embracing
him and showing him love.
- I was gonna say, I loved that.
I love that it actually did that.
It wasn't like the typical
like, oh, it's hard.
'Cause yes, it is hard for people.
I have friends that it was hard for
and some of their family
don't talk to them,
but some are embraced, they embrace it,
they love you, it's not a big deal.
And I think we don't hear
those stories enough.
- That's why it was so
important for me to show.
'Cause I do a lot of work
with Covenant House who,
over the years they have,
a lot of kids are homeless
because they were put out
because they were LGBTQ plus.
And to see...
- Can you imagine that?
We're both parents.
- It's so horrible.
I don't even know how, listen,
I couldn't even imagine the love that
I have for my child.
- [Kelly] Infinite.
- Infinite, you know?
And to think because of
the way they were born,
you would really just
discard them, is shocking
to me that people can do that.
- Yeah, I don't get that either.
I think it's really cool that you use
a powerful message in such a powerful way
because people love to laugh.
They love to, they're already
a part of this character.
- [Madea] Thank you baby. I appreciate it.
I appreciate it so much.
I appreciate so much.
I appreciate babe. I've
been around long time.
- This is what I love too.
I love that you took Madea,
and you made these posters.
I was dying.
- Oh listen.
- Wait, so here's some of the posters.
This is the frown.
(everyone laughing)
Which is amazing.
Wait, this is Madeagerton.
- [Tyler] That's right, you said it right.
- Madeagerton. Oh my God.
First of all, wait, keep it up.
Guy on the right is the
creepiest one of us.
It's awesome, it's my favorite one.
It's so funny.
- Brendan O'Carroll, Mrs.
Brown. He's huge in Europe.
- Oh my God. I know.
I love it, it's amazing.
It's so great. And wait,
this is awesome too.
Shout out to Ma-delle 90.
- [Tyler] Ma-delle, Ma-delle, yeah.
- My favorite thing is you said 90.
- She does. So Adele did 30.
That's Madea's, 90 year old album.
So, and her song was called "Hellerr".
- Hellerr. You should do a music...
- Album? Do a whole album.
- Yes, cover them all.
- That's great.
- [Kelly] And change it.
Wait, speaking of how positive you are
and I love your messages. I love this.
You once said negativity screams,
and positivity whispers.
- Yeah.
- That is such a powerful statement.
And I want you to talk about it a bit,
but I also wanted to
say, it's hilarious to me
because there's this song
that recently came out.
I might say her name wrong, I'm so sorry.
Avery Anna, I think is her name
and it's a song called narcissist
and there was this line in
it that's kind of similar
and it's, "you lose your
voice when you yell too much".
And I love that physically
you lose your voice
when you yell too much, but
all also you lose your power.
'Cause I feel like people
confuse power and force.
- Yes.
- And it's so powerful, the
whispering is more powerful.
- I've never seen really
powerful people yell. Right?
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- When you're powerful,
you make decisions.
You don't do all the yelling
and screaming, right?
But no, I said that because everything
that bombards us all
day long is negativity,
if you think about it, on
your phone, on the news,
everything is negativity,
and it gets so much attention
and so much pickup, right?
But if somebody does
something kind for someone
or helps them rebuild a
house that burned down
or saves someone's dog or,
you don't hear that everywhere. Right?
So I wish there was more balance of it
because we're bombarded
with all the negativity.
I wish there was more
balance of the positivity
so people could start to feel good.
That's why I wanted to bring Madea back.
- Me too and I feel like unfortunately
it's a bit of supply and
demand. We have to demand that.
'Cause the reason why they
supply it is cause people...
They like a train wreck,
it's like they like it,
and that's unfortunate,
but it is a good shift.
I think that would be good
for society in general.
- I would hope so.
I'm worried about where
we're headed as a society.
- [Kelly] Jesus take the wheel.
- Yeah. Literally, right.
- I had to literally like,
I'm going through a divorce.
It's been a rough two years.
I had to literally turn off the news,
which I don't like doing.
'Cause I like to be informed,
but it was just too much.
Like I found myself in therapy,
just bawling for the world,
myself, everything.
I was like, everything's on fire.
I was like, what's happening?
But it's not, there are
kind things happening.
- But then you have these
beautiful beings looking
at you, your kids, if you
hadn't been through that,
you know, they wouldn't be here right?
- [Kelly] Yes, absolutely.
- And you have to constantly refocus on,
"This is good. This is okay. I'm okay."
And, and tell yourself you're okay.
We're gonna move through this.
We're gonna get to a better place.
And, and before you know it, you're there.
I know it sounds like a cliche.
- No, it would be easier
to move and navigate that
though through a more positive
kind of society instead
of everybody, you know, kind of attacking.